the Joe Rogan experience have you seen
all the [ __ ] that points to the fact
that this came from a lab well you know
what's so funny I was talking that I
can't say anything but they were like
this is a chemical thing that just got
out of hand they were like they [ __ ]
up like they were working on how to
mitigate viruses that's what they were
doing they were working on and they had
viruses in this lab in Wuhan and they
think it came out and that's one of the
reasons why they think China immediately
blamed it on the wet market they said
whenever China blames it on something
always look deeper
there are a ton there's a ton of
scientists that are pointing to that
there's one French virologist Jamie I'll
send you this there's a French biologist
who identified HIV and this French
biologist was looking at this disease
and he was like this is not a disease
that came from nature no this is a
disease that came from a lab did you see
that that Facebook video where the this
some series on Netflix what is it it's a
series on Netflix that takes place in
China that like two or three years ago
they called the coronavirus and he like
played the thing really yeah it was like
episode 13 season 3 or something like
that of this show Jesus Christ man they
knew this stuff was happening
well people knew that it was always a
possibility I'm in this text thread but
it's here now and it's just like the the
reset of like oh that's nothing that's
interesting like what is doing to our TV
industry like it feels like everything
has become you too
you know trying to do you right now
everybody is the thing is they're trying
to do it but they're not adapting right
they're not adapting to the fact they
got no artists so they're doing these
wack-ass monologues you know who's doing
it well who bill maher yeah bill my
money isn't having fun with it he's
having a great time he's also he has
here French virologist I'll send you
this right now Jamie hold on a second
Bill Maher has some great [ __ ] rants
I mean these are tweeted twice to him
that where I said Bravo yes are you
playing it on my phone no where does it
sound coming from I just sent it to you
yeah his [ __ ] [ __ ] has been great
yeah hilarious and also you know he's
he's pushing all the buttons you know
he's he's doing comedy he's doing like
real edgy comedy while he's pointing out
how crazy this all is I appreciate him
right now he's a guy who's on the left
that I really I really liked the fact
that he doesn't give in to all the
craziness he doesn't give in to the the
lunacy of left-wing policies he still
he's still like rational yeah about it
all although clearly left-wing biased
he's still rational yeah but it still
goes with comedy but it was one yeah I
watched I don't know man
I liked him a lot and I watched like a
buts coming I watched no cuz I watched
some of his stuff and I feel like it's
two things you should have me on this
show basically because he's always he
would have you on the show he's always
talking about kids you don't want to
[ __ ] you talking about and he's always
talking about but but I love I love how
he attacks it like he knows but it's
like that's that's your [ __ ]
yeah that's not it or he'll be talking
about he did this whole rant about why
can't we call it the China disease and
yeah and I was listening to a Chinese
American on on the daily he's talking
about her experience of feeling like
being an asian-american here was always
like a probationary experience as long
as I did the right things and stayed out
the way people left me alone but when
this came up just for going outside
people like you [ __ ] Chinese you know
in and it's kind of like so is to me I
love watching him because it's because
it's also these blind spots that he just
his whole rant was really about stop
these wet markets you can do it he
didn't have to do the well here's the
other side of it just when they called
it the Chinese virus they don't call
anything a virus
in a country they would call it the
Wuhan virus dislike they called Lyme
disease Lyme disease that was one of the
examples that I used or like you know
SARS or MERS or some Middle Eastern
respiratory didn't make that point they
call it and that's what I'm saying
problem is yeah the problem is that he's
trying to do comedy and he's trying to
make a point at the same time and really
the right way would be call it the Wuhan
yes if they called but when they called
it Co vid 19 then it becomes the whole
world's problems that's one of the
difference between that what that
journalist in Germany was saying to the
head of China you know he was saying
that and then the Chinese guy was saying
hey this is the whole world's problems
the whole world's pandemic but yeah
kinda but it did come from a [ __ ] if
it did if it did come from a lab you
know right we should call it the lab
created Wuhan virus there you go but
it's more specific here it is
inaccurately claims the novel
coronavirus is man-made and contains
genetic material from HIV okay so this
guy is Nobel laureate Luc Montaigne
speak French so um how do we know that
this guy's correct it says series nomic
analysis and can you make that a little
bit it says indicates the virus has a
natural origin it was not engineered the
so called unique protein sequence
insertions found the two towns of
nineteen corner of ours can be found in
many other organisms not just HIV but
that doesn't mean it's organic or
natural in origin see I think that we
are right now in this period of
conflicting information and you're gonna
get it bouncing back and forth from
protic on but I've read multiple sources
that seem and and from respected
scientist it seemed to indicate that
there's a distinct possibility that came
from that lab one of the things they're
saying is the actual bats that the
sequence the genome when they when they
when they found the genetics for this
virus the bats that tested you know that
where this originated from were the same
exact same exact location as the bats
that they do research on in this lab and
the lab is four miles away I mean it's
not it's not outside the realm of
possible right and we're in the
wheelhouse right there
yeah obviously I'm a [ __ ] I don't know
[ __ ] about viruses yeah other than what
I read but when China says all
definitely a wet market nothing to see
here so it's a great point look deeper
yeah I don't know I mean maybe it was a
wet market maybe it wasn't a wet market
right yeah well the wet markets are
[ __ ] gross you know it is but that's
also a sad thing about you're trying to
feed a billion people and you're feeding
them wildlife you know a lot of what
they're eating is wildlife their
equivalents are like squirrels and yeah
exactly yeah just they're eating
whatever they they can eat
[Applause]